all right welcome back to game on vegas
boulder city's own barry and jill
lagan aren't allowed to watch their
sharp shooting daughter lexi
compete in the olympics in person it's
disappointing but they did the hard part
they raised a
really a high character olympian here
for a special year with family and many
community first i'll tell you what the
legends have another tale to tell
for one of nevada's most storied cities
john treach picks up the story
from the peaceful to the powerful
boulder city is at the soul
of southern nevada but for the first
time in its charming history
this proud silver state city has a
contender for olympic gold
i'm going to the olympics it's not just
a
not just a pipe dream or just something
down you know a long long road it's
right here i'm right there
she's a sharp shooter with a soft touch
kind but with killer consistency on
average the
the 10 rings about the size of an eraser
head off of a pencil
and in order to be competitive
internationally you need to be hitting
that
eraser head about seven to eight
times out of ten the foundation of this
firearm shooting phenomenon
comes naturally lexi's dad barry is a
25-year metro police officer
and an instructor at the range he
retires
on her first day of competition a lot of
guys they have sons and
my son plays football my son plays
baseball well my daughter shoots and
that's
that's excellent for me to say not only
does she shoot she's achieved the
highest mark possible by getting to go
to the olympics
as for lexi's family the only ones with
more tenure in town are the bighorn
sheep
granddaddy came here to be one of the
first to be the first hard hat diver on
lake mead
and then my grandfather was with the
bureau of mines and helped
with some of the tunneling and the
history gets richer
one of lexi's relatives was a high
skiller on the hoover dam construction
and her great grandmother gloria is the
oldest living showgirl
she dated howard hughes four generations
later lexi is taking flight to tokyo
now i get to represent it on this world
stage it's something that i'm very proud
of and i just really love my community
lexi lagan boulder city's perfect
pioneer